みんな
俺の髪色見て
どうもカイマーは一般的に見るとかなり明るい方だとは思うんですけどもこれ僕の家で
はまだまだ暗いんですこの写真をご覧下さい
どうぞ見てくださいどこにいる奴のどこに列のどこにれ妻は辛い
本来
こんなに俺が市場からいいんだけど何たらおりは中退けられない
全米見た時に僕が飛ぶ簡略なったら中の下なんでダメなんですよ
この世でも全然まだまだ暗いんですよもう開運額をで一番明るくしてくらいなんです
けどもここにさらに
ブリッジをしてもっともっと明るくしようと思ったんですけどもこれなどまだまだ
みんなまとめるてっぺんとしては
雨というわけで何かネットで調べたんですけども世の中に打っているグリーンの中で
最も強い
めちゃを強いと言われているフルーツを発表しましたこちらですハイブリーチとか
明るい日について金が髪の毛金で誰がいると思うんですよ
がまさにこんな感じねこういう感じでなんか女性の人が男の人とか髪は金髪でいると
思うんですけども最も強い女が bleach にはそんなざっ
年が一切ございませんなんたるシンプルなデザインだって思っちゃうんですけどもて
フィットホイップ入りしてですね
みてくださいもう金髪様子がありませんいくつとこまでいけばもうするようになって
しまいます
怖いようなこれやばいを見せることやばいよこれなんか市内とに際あるんですけど量が
多いと発熱するらしいです
でイッツァツイート約90度ですよ約90度まで発熱するしていた島家でホラーこれ
大丈夫使ってこれやまずで強いこれまだ大丈夫なのこれ
助けてください頭が出来ましたがやりましょうっていうわけでこのはいベースの金髪
状態にさ
に史上最強の入る率をになるとどんな色になれるのか
なぜ僕はですねこのメンツより暗いわけないカードですよよしな早速使っていき
ましょう
では早速やっていきましょうね本当に怖いんですけど
夏じゃん夏ならもう何キロになってもいいと思うんですよ皆さん今度発熱で90度比べ
たら普通に火傷してるんでまずで調整ますまあ国の日本はより良い綺麗な金髪になれば
いいと思ってるのでまだハゲたら上げたで揚げる時に上げます般若偽物入れる時のブツ
切れます
それでいいです
本のポイン
をなぜかよじゃあっはいっぷり5
こんなの真っ白と言ってやばいんだけどこんなことになるのだからコレなどとついハイ
ブリッジの概念をこうしてる人ハイブリッジって骨金とかなんですけども入る5時ごろ
城みたいな考えてねこっちはこれマジで怖いさて普通部に取材こんなに入ってない
じゃん入れるの多くね1剤がここ入ってるだけバック
ねえのって怖い呼ばせハーって待ってわかんないわかんない1対3ということべてんの
本当に待ってだって
っていう国事例頑張ってますねます本当にマツコは過去一番声ですね90度が出たら歳
やけどそれじゃ
同じやってみましょうとりあえずあってこれを開けた初めてショップも1ますよ
いたはいこれを入れます
までどこに異例の待てうどこにいるの待てどこに縁のあっこっこれをつけますありがと
ラブライブ
に混ぜます
まあつくねこれ強い思いでくださるないよう前川調合っていうんだね総合しなきゃいけ
ないのでですクリームじゃんだったのですみだ
グッズはこのためにつけていますいけない
通りの買ってくれ風邪の予防するといいよや鍵や靴よねーまためちゃんこつでこれ
爆ないね自分はっと音米派が出なかった
時間計ってなかった
ああ今からそいつちょっとね根が明るい髪はそのベビーだけでっていう取り込みその
おかげで言ってくれた方はそれ導入と思いますでしょうがちょっと得ない
[音楽]
色は待ってくださいね待って白くないですかムラが出てしまっているんですけど
めっちゃ白い
あっはっは
うんじゃあみんなと比べたらどうかわかんないんですけどやよ買ってもそんなもんだが
ちぎれるかと思ったね不全でちじれずに済んだんでなんとか助かりましたありがとう
ございましたいやもうこれ以上アムニス声者を育てるのはもう無理ですねちょっと今年
の残りの夏はこの色で乗り切ろうと思います最後に
ままに僕の髪の毛の色を送ってあげましょう
どうばっかりて来たーー
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
me あった